proposers look I won't mince words
they're words they're not meat America
is in crisis our borders are open and a
mysterious customer service robot keeps
asking me to dial to Paris XO in short
we have an immigration problem whenever
I have a problem I turned a citizen
journalist Coby Libby the left is
painting the right as a heartless
immigrant tagine party how wrong are
they objectify ibly wrong Jordan
conservatives love immigrants we just
want people to emigrate the right way
learn to speak English exactly similar
to our custom that's totally and be
white yes no no no no I didn't say that
you didn't have to Jordan
I read your subtext loud and clear let's
just come out and say it we want to keep
America white conservatives have been
dancing around this for too long and
excuse me for saying this Jordan but
white people are famously bad at dancing
going away we're going with immigration
we have a complete demographic change in
the United States let's stop talking
about the a word amnesty and talk more
about the a word assimilation nothing
affects democracy more the demographic
change their goal is to change your
country forever and they're succeeding
by the way maybe I don't want to live in
a country looks nothing like the country
I grew up in is that bigoted yes it is
but not bigoted enough
just be clear don't talk around it like
an awkward kid buying condoms for the
first time just say what you mean
like Arizona representative David
stringer two weeks ago he called
immigration an existential threat to the
US and said there aren't enough white
kids to go around ah it's so liberating
to say exactly what you think out loud
this barbeque sucks your baby is weird
how could you be on board with this
conservatives need to be honest about
wanting to keep America white immigrants
of color need to know the America
they're walking into specifically a
hostile one okay Kobe but just to be
clear you're not white not white yet but
I do have a plan I've cracked the code
for immigrant success I don't often
discuss this but my father is actually
an immigrant from West Africa but he's
the good kind of immigrant who worked
hard to create a whiter life for his
children he married a woman so pale she
sunburns at the very thought of going
outside and if I continue this pattern
my great-grandson will be so white he
will look like he colonized something
he'll be clad in Argyle at all times
he'll use summer as a verb he'll have a
polo horse that knows how to play
croquet he'll use the word Township
he'll you're a female colleagues idea in
a meeting and be sure it was his own you
don't know what a shell company is
without being told he'll be so white
he'll call Tucker Carlson's
great-grandson urban and sure it'll
it'll take a couple of generations that
will have to seduce a lot of white women
but that will still take a lot less time
than change in America's attitudes
towards race
okay Wow
Kobe intense sorry George little carried
away there you're not gonna call the
cops on me for yelling are you of course
not why I just keep getting wider and
wider cobiella be the fight continue the
fight continues you you a deep state
operative is sent by George Soros to
take away my Second Amendment rights and
for speedy soy burgers no well then
prove it click and subscribe and join
the opposition now